you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with hyperkalemia a
problem in which too much potassium is
in the blood this video will help you
understand more about hyperkalemia
including its symptoms common risk
factors and
management there are often no symptoms
of hyperkalemia however mild symptoms
that appear over time may include nausea
muscle weakness numbness or
tingling more severe symptoms that
happen suddenly and require immediate
Medical Care may include shortness of
breath heart
palpitations chest pain nausea or
vomiting the body needs to keep the
right amount of potassium in the blood
for nerves and muscles including the
heart to work normally potassium is one
of several minerals that the body gets
from
food most of it is stored in the cells
of the body and a small amount stays
outside the cells as well as in the
blood healthy kidneys help to maintain
normal levels of potassium in the blood
by passing excess potassium out of the
body in urine there are risk factors
that may damage or impair the kidneys or
prevent the body from keeping potassium
in its cells leading to
hyperkalemia some common risk factors
for hyperkalemia include chronic kidney
disease a condition where the kidneys
gradually lose their ability to work
properly heart failure a condition where
the heart has trouble pumping blood to
the rest of the
body high blood pressure or hypertension
a disease where the force of Blood on
the walls of the arteries is too high
and may lead to complications like
chronic kidney disease and heart
failure diabetes a disease where too
much sugar is in the blood and taking
medications for these or other
conditions which may prevent the kidneys
or the body from maintaining normal
levels of pottassium
a doctor May do a blood test to check
the body's potassium level for most
people a normal range is from about 3.5
to
5.0 hyperkalemia is a potassium level
greater than
five if you are at risk for high
potassium speak with your doctor about
ways to manage your potassium levels you
may be ask to avoid or limit eating
foods that are high in potassium in
addition your doctor may make changes to
your
medications to help minimize your risk
of hyperkalemia it's important that you
know your risk factors pottassium level
foods to avoid and medications you're
taking if you have questions about
hyperkalemia or any medications you have
been prescribed talk to your doctor it
is important to take your medications as
directed and Report any side effects you
have